believe it or not it was a year ago this
week that a constellation of left-wing
activist groups
cooked up a series of outlandish lies
designed to keep brett kavanaugh off the
supreme court
the national news media as doubt as you
remember joined the smear campaign they
repeated and magnified
the slurs but in the end it was to no
effect kavanaugh was confirmed
anyway why because not a single
allegation against him
turned out to be true not one and so
they're only lasting effect was to
traumatize brett kavanaugh's wife and
children
and yet the left never to this day
apologized for their dishonesty or their
profound
cruelty nor did they ever accept defeat
they never do
accept defeat why because when politics
is your religion
acknowledging reality looks like sin and
so it continues over the weekend the new
york times
revived the attacks on brett kavanaugh
the newspaper ran a story an excerpt
from a book written by two of its
reporters
that claim that while in college more
than 30 years ago
kavanaugh exposed himself in effect to
another student while drunk at a
party it was the flimsiest kind of
charge where did it come from well
it came second hand from a single
classmate of
kavanaugh's a man who worked as a
left-wing activist
later worked for the clintons in fact so
20 years ago no credible news
organization would have run a story like
that on the basis of that
sourcing the times didn't hesitate
and it was picked up everywhere of
course instantly on nbc's cable channel
for example
they immediately denounced brett
kavanaugh as a gang rapist
i've never heard of a guy who's a
one-time rapist i've never heard of a
guy who's a one-time sexual assaulter
i grew up with guys like this he's from
around this area right he's the fifth
guy in a gang rape
okay he's the guy who comes in after
he's drunk because everybody else
encourages him he can get away with it
he's been pretty much covered his entire
life
it is amazed me that we have an
administration that out of the millions
of people who are qualified in this
country of all races and genders they
consistently find men who beat
abuse and sexually assault women imagine
saying something like that about
somebody
when there's no evidence that it's true
and a lot of evidence that it's not
but they didn't hesitate democratic
presidential candidates meanwhile
demanded that kavanaugh
be removed by force immediately from the
supreme court watch this
what's become clear is that that he
should be impeached the house absolutely
has the ability
to impeach him and do you believe then
that he is
essentially a sexual predator or that he
was at some point
yeah i believe i believe that he engaged
in the conduct
uh that was described and given the fact
that it appears
as though brett kavanaugh lied under
oath
which is a crime i think that he has
disqualified himself for service
on the supreme court and he should step
down or he should be impeached
a sexual predator who must be impeached
okay but wait here's a late breaking
addition to this story it turns out that
the woman
the supposedly happened to the alleged
victim back at yale more than 30 years
ago
turns out that person has no memory
whatsoever
of the incident now the paper knew that
but somehow neglected to include it in
their account probably because it
strongly suggests that their story is
once again
a total crock yet another lie they
should have told you that
and they didn't it's dishonest of course
and you'd think it would spur the
democratic candidates the one who called
for
kavanaugh's impeachment to rethink their
positions new evidence
maybe that would shape their view but no
not at all they sound exactly as they
did a year ago
remember this there's no presumption of
innocence or
guilt when you have a nominee before you
we have a constitutional duty
to get to the bottom of these
allegations judge brett kavanaugh
has a responsibility to come forward
with evidence to rebut them kavanaugh
who is seeking a lifetime appointment to
the supreme court
and who i think now bears the burden of
disproving these allegations
rather than dr ford and ms ramirez to
those who i hear
say over and over this isn't fair
to judge kavanaugh he's entitled to due
process
what about the presumption of innocence
until proven guilty
he's not entitled to those because we're
not actually seeking to convict him
uh-huh we're not trying to convict him
he's trying to destroy him
and his family so no due process no
presumption of innocence fairness
irrelevant whatever they tell you don't
let him tell you that justice has any
role in this of course this is a pure
power grab
the left feels entitled to run the
country truly entitled to and they feel
entitled to control the supreme court
they don't and it drives them crazy
cabinet frustrates their political hopes
so any
smear against him is acceptable no
matter what it is but don't kid yourself
it's not just about destroying brett
kavanaugh
he's ancillary it's about destroying the
entire legitimacy of our third branch of
government the judiciary
plenty of the left are using the
kavanaugh saga to justify
packing the court adding more justices
to
to make it reliably left-wing or
to change the rules so they can remove
any judge the left doesn't approve of
this is the opposite of what the third
branch was meant to do or be
the judiciary was meant to change slowly
the courts change over
decades rather than in response to a
single election cycle
that's the way it was designed and for a
reason and for more than 200 years it's
worked
but to the modern left that's totally
intolerable they're committed to
remaking this country completely
right now america needs a new system
they tell us one with
open borders and far fewer pesky
individual
rights rights like the freedom to speak
clearly
out loud the freedom of expression the
right to bear arms the freedom of
religion
no to create this new utopia of obedient
happy serfs
they're going to have to destroy all of
that two centuries of precedent and
tradition
maybe even destroy the country itself
whatever they're happy to do that
as rob spear noted when you make omelets
you break eggs